y'a un moniteur de tpb cac lâché nolwenn
leroy pendant un live dans tpm c'est pas
jean-michel à je sais moi bonjour c'est
vrai alors c'est du one le dit c'est qui
c'est qui qu'a dit un truc pas sympa
ouais abbas et jean-michel bon alors
c'est moi qui ai gagné
[Rires]
vous pouvez gagner mais il arrêtait là
regretté ahmed abidi je ne sais pas
j'espère pas pas trop horrible j'espère
ça donne plus mais je fais les cheveux
pour ma décharge on crée d'abord
[Musique]
je vais aller
[Applaudissements]
décidée
à l'aller charge huawei avait ramené
quatre aux amériques en ce moment le
plus comme disait ce geste c'est moche
mais ça c'est la vieillissante je viens
de complètement guéri jeudi j mal de
tout mot je suis comme teddy daniels et
une catastrophe totale journée suicide
du match pour tout le monde
mais évidemment qu elle est merveilleuse
et ses fans le savent bien plus que moi
elle fantastique évidemment basque
détaillé il est content je suis désolé
quand même comme ça c'est aux racines
géante n'est pas du tout rega non mes
chaussures vous êtes un amour / par
contre les roses est ce qu'on peut aimer
donner parce que j'ai peut-être les
ventes ce soir
[Rires]